This is Brian Intithar senior creative director
at Insomniac games.
Thank you for all of your amazing
feedback to our demo it to showcase
earlier this year.
Marvel's Spider-Man two is filled
with an amazing story and story missions,
but today I'm here to provide you
with a first
look at how the open world experience
is evolving and how the game is built
to take full advantage of the PlayStation
five.
The first thing you notice is
that our city has nearly doubled in size
with the addition of two iconic New York
boroughs, Queens and Brooklyn.
And we've introduced the Web Wings,
an entirely new mechanic that we combined
with Web swinging, allows you
to traverse the city in a whole new way
and at faster speeds than ever before.
Whether it's a neighborhood
backdrop of queens or the fireworks
that light up the sky over
Coney Island, exploring
these areas will feel much different
to the towering skyscrapers of Manhattan,
while also delivering memorable locales
like Peter Parker's old
stomping grounds in Midtown
High and Miles Morales.
Its current place of learning,
Broken Vision's Academy.
Hey, Miles, what's up?
Speaking of our heroes, Marvel's
Spider-Man two will introduce the ability
to switch between the two
while crawlers in the upper world.
And thanks to the power of PlayStation
five,
you can make that switch almost instantly.
Delivering a bigger city playing.
It's not one but two.
Spider heroes were big goals for Marvel's
Spider-Man two.
But this time around,
it was equally important
to provide a greater sense of exploration
and discovery as you progress
the main story.
A number of new activities.
The storylines will become available.
The majority of those will now
be represented by visual cues in the world
that grab your attention,
such as a flock of Cravens talon drones,
certainly a building
mysterious symbol projected into the sky
or even an unfamiliar spider
by ping emitting from one of the rooftops.
Many activities
like the Hunter's cloak blinds overlook
the Big Apple lead to even greater
challenges, yet yield worthy rewards
and new information about Marvel's
greatest hunter crater.
Others will lead to a climactic showdown
with Marvel villains
not yet seen in the Spider-Man universe.
The Spider heroes have new air
tech in the lenses.
Their masks providing a quick
glimpse of activities are discovered
or help locate new ones yet
to be revealed.
You can always refer to the upgraded
friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man app
to quickly track nearby areas of interest.
The app will also include
incoming requests from those who call
Marvel's New York home.
Some will ask for either Spider here
to help, while others,
like the students of Brooklyn
Vision's Calling Upon.
Miles, will require you
to put on the mask of a specific hero.
All these activities, including crime,
stop from the game's various enemy
factions, also now feed
into the new district primary system,
which even provides more rewards
and blocks a brand new fast travel system.
As you can see here,
the PlayStation five, it's
SSD means you can move across the city
with very little downtime.
Finally, the more city you explore
and the more activities
you complete, the more ways you'll be able
to customize your spider hero.
This includes mastering additional combat
abilities and traversal skills,
acquiring improving gadgets,
upgrading to the new suit touch system,
and, of course,
unlocking additional spider suits.
And we're talking lots and lots of suits.
Marvel's Spider-Man two will feature over
65 suits from the comics, movies
and multiple original designs.
And thanks to the all new suit
style system
you'll now
have more than 200 different ways
to outfit your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man.
On behalf of insomniac games.
We couldn't be more excited about what
this expanding city has to offer
and all the new ways
you'll experience Marvel's New York.
We look forward to seeing you
swinging around in Marvel's Spider-Man two
when it launches October 20th,
only on PlayStation five.
also got to look at the symbiote surge.
Basically,
Peter goes into rage mode Allah,
God of war
and wrecks everything in the vicinity.
There's a cool down on it,
just like rage, mourning God of war.
So after you've attacked everybody
for a little bit, the timer will wear out
and you'll have to rely on your core
abilities.
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my new Marvel Spider-Man
2 trailer video.
They released a whole bunch
more gameplay footage.
And what's going on with the actual story?
A bunch of the differences.
So we'll break it all down
They're even a bunch of Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
Easter eggs in those too.
So a lot of people are wondering
if they're setting up
spider-verse stuff in the game.
They did have a big cameo scene
from Insomniac's Spider-Man
in Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse,
so that would not surprise me
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the views.
What I'll probably do
is when the game actually comes out,
I'll give away a couple of copies
and my videos,
the game will be dropping when Loki season
two episodes are happening.
So I'll probably do the giveaway
during my Loki episodes.
the Spider-Verse Easter eggs
that people are thinking
that they're seeing are side
missions in the game.
We're yet to click unfamiliar spider bots
in some of the bites directly reference
characters from the Spider-Verse movies.
Gangi also says that a person who plays
the bots is millions of miles away
as in there in another universe,
all spider-verse.
So it is always possible.
Like Sony is behind insomniac,
Sony makes the Spider-Verse movies.
They reference Insomniac's Spider-Man
into the Spider-Verse movies.
It makes sense
that Sony would go for that synergy
and try to reference the Spider-Verse
movies on the games side of things.
maybe if we're lucky, we'll see more.
Spider-Man Ps5 Easter Eggs Inside
Spider-Man Beyond the Spider-Verse.
In a couple of years,
I've already done a teaser trailer video
for Spider-Man Beyond the Spider-Verse,
so I'll link it at the end of this
and down the description below.
maybe,
Maybe they'll be more spider-verse stuff
in whatever Spider-Man
three video game winds up looking like.
Assuming that Insomniac does
the Spider-Man three,
it makes sense that they would.
They've been making so much money
on this line of Spider-Man games.
most of the features
that they show off in all the gameplay
is that the people asked for
in the previous Spider-Man games
like Spider-Man, Miles Morales
game in the original Spider-Man PS4 game.
So this means that there's
a lot of quality of life upgrades
in addition to this
just being a much better version
of the mechanics from the original games.
we also got that clip of them
talking about the Symbiote Spider-Man suit
and what that mode is going to be like,
kind of like a berserker mode
that has its own cooldown,
which makes sense
just based on the way the symbiote works
when Spider-Man is using it in the comics,
The whole idea is that the symbiote
basically boosts all of his natural
abilities, basically pushes him way
past his natural limits.
So for brief periods, he's way stronger,
way faster, but way more vicious.
at some point during the game, Spider-Man
will get rid of the symbiote
and will get full blown venom.
And they confirmed that Venom will be
a playable character during the game
now, if you're still confused about who's
going to actually become
the Venom character in the game,
that's supposed to be Harry Osborn.
As far as I know,
I don't know what point of the game
Harry is going to turn into Venom,
but it's all a continuation
of that plot point
in the first movie with Norman Osborn
using the symbiote to try and heal Harry
during the last big trailer,
Harry was talking to Peter
as if he'd already been cured,
like he had a new lease on life.
So it sounds like at that point
in the game the symbiote has already done
its work healing him and in the process
of turning into Venom begins.
There was also the other trailer footage
that made it seem like Spider-Man
gets the symbiote temporarily in a while.
He has it here.
He is still in the process of dying
and he's trying to catch the lizard before
Kraven can kill him.
Because Lizard Kurt Connor's
is the only person who can save Harry.
This version of the Lizard also looks way
more hardcore than we've seen before.
generally the timeline, though, on
who has the symbiote
and when they have it during
the game is a little fuzzy.
But at some point
we have Harry turning it to Venom
and it sounds like that's later
in the game.
Tony. Todd will also be doing
the Voice of Venom.
And he sounds amazing.
There was like a brief teaser
for that in one of the last trailers.
We're going to kill you.
all the talk of venom healing the planet,
so to speak,
makes it sound like you want to play
into the symbiotes.
Easter egg for the comics and want to
cover the earth in more symbiotes.
Basically give Symbiotes
to everybody else on the planet
there were a bunch of new suits
that they showed up.
They're supposed to be at least
65 different
unique ones that you get during the game.
They should have only a handful
during the last couple of trailers.
It's still a bunch. We don't know about.
But probably the biggest one
everybody was getting hyped about this
week was Tobey Maguire's venom suit
from the Spider-Man three movie.
They also confirmed Spider-Man 2099 suit.
Like I said, more spider-verse Easter eggs
there's a miles Morales
version of the 2099 suit.
during the digital deluxe trailer here,
they show off a bunch of suits
that you get.
Most of them are not based on comic book
versions of the season, like unique ones
that they created just for the game
based on a couple comic book Easter eggs,
but mostly inspired by stuff in real life.
right now, the closest
we have to Miles Morales
getting a version of the symbiote
is the biomechanical suit.
But that's not meant to be a symbiote
or venom Easter egg.
they said that that design is based
more on H.R.
Giger designs,
more of like an organic type of design.
but we're getting close to Miles Morales
symbiote Easter eggs.
This is actually what Miles Morales
looks like when he's wearing a symbiote.
Maybe that's something that they'll tease
during the third game or some future
video game.
We'll see Right now,
the only references we've gotten
to Venom or Symbiote Spider-Man
in the Spider-Verse movies,
like on the other side
of the equation here
so far were a couple of quick cameo scenes
in Spider-Man across the spider-verse
there was a brief scene
where the spider crosses over
into the Venom universe and sees Mrs.
Chan steal some Venom mints,
which were made by Brock's Candy
during the montage of Spider-Man 2099,
explaining the spider-verse
in the web of Life and Destiny.
He's referencing the canon events
that are very bad.
He shows a montage of symbiote versions
of Spider-Man in Venom from the comics.
one of the panels shows Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man in Spider-Man three,
trying to get rid of the Venom symbiote.
we'll probably get more trailers for this
as we get closer to the game coming out.
And I'll start my giveaway
as soon as the Loki episodes start.
So be sure to enable alerts
from my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here for my Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse teaser trailer
video and click here for my Ahsoka Episode
6 Trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!